[Musique]
d'eau de faire ou de terre tous les
chemins mènent à paris
[Musique]
sur les bords de la seine le premier
visage paris ne nous étonne pas nous
l'attendions c'est celui de l'amour
amoureux de la scène où les tuileries il
ne tourne le dos le visage du bonheur et
masques h et surprenant un autre visage
celui du réveil coquette capitale
matinale qui se balaie ces poussettes se
nettoie
ce fait briller et déploie cette terreur
sans se soucier des premiers flâneurs
[Musique]
dans toutes les rues la ville s'est mise
en marche pour vivre il faut manger et
pour manger il faut payer et sur les
visages de ces femmes ou disons que la
vie est encore plus cher quand on n'a
plus 20 ans
[Musique]
soudain c'est une course une course au
trésor
c'est l'heure du pape
[Musique]
avec les voitures les passants danse
maintenant un étrange ballet figures
compliquées aux règles qui s'appelle
règlement
[Musique]
mais au nul n'est à l'abri des surprises
et des difficultés
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
chacun au fond du coeur à son visage
préféré de paris pour cet homme paris ce
sont les pigeons amour exclusif qui
remplit toute une vie et commence à tout
âge
[Musique]
pour les peintres le visage de paris
c'est celui qui restera sur leurs toiles
lettres d'amour en couleur sans cesse
recommencé
[Musique]
à montmartre ces lettres d'amour on les
ventes aux étrangers pour qu'ils
n'oublient pas leur aventure
[Musique]
ces visages d'ailleurs en partie de
paris
[Musique]
on
sans eux sans cet anglais à moustache
sens et péruviennes volubile
cette suissesse ravi ce guide
scandinaves la butte aurait l'air -
parisienne
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui
voici le prodige une grande demoiselle
de faits de boue infatigable sourire de
dentelle au suspendues dans le ciel
[Musique]
autre sourire de paris ce jardin
mais en miniature au milieu des
tuileries a été aménagé pour faire
plaisir aux petits garçons en y lançant
leur bateau rouge
il donne à paris autant de visages marin
heureux sans tempête et sans naufrage
comme il est dit sur l'écusson de la
ville
[Musique]
un autre rive de l'existence des jardins
font le bonheur des plus vieux le grand
repos commence ici dans ce dialogue muet
entre ceux qui furent aussi à leur
époque les amoureux de paris
[Musique]
et c'est comme leur enfance qui rit à
leurs côtés à l'heure du 4 heures
[Musique]
à l'heure aussi où guignols de son
bateau dirige la symphonie des
étonnements et des rires en cascade
[Musique]
dans les jardins se vident le rêve s'y
installent
les enfants songeur prennent des chemins
de fer et le fut mais ira paris
imaginaire
où les ballons de couleur sont plus
grands que l'arc de triomphe
où les soucoupes volantes parle d'un
autre monde
[Musique]
on
oh
dans l'obscurité descente les images
familières s'efface
[Musique]
et bientôt la nuit du nez on met en
route le carrousel de ses lumières
[Musique]
oh
un jour nouveau se lève dans le silence
ouaté du matin
cette eau froide comme un phare glace et
maintenant ce crack clan nous révéler un
autre visage de paris
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ce pêcheur ses ouvriers cet écolier pour
dissiper les brouillards 4 millions de
regards et de sourires amène toujours le
printemps ne soyons donc pas étonné de
retrouver hirondelles fidèle au rendez
vous le visage par quoi tout commence et
finit l'amour
[Musique]